so from your site you say that tiny your
documentary is the story of building a
house from scratch and it explores how
we live and find ourselves at home our
relationship and identities with our
home so if we are gained a sense of
identity from where we live why do you
think in most people's minds they equate
bigger as better what what is this you
know cadillac escalade it's hung bees we
somehow think that bigger is better and
it doesn't equate to more self-esteem or
we feel more powerful yeah i mean i
think it's it's also probably a product
of you know just advertising and media
you know in our country over the past 50
years you know really trying to sell us
the idea that you know why wouldn't you
want to have more if you can you know
and and without necessarily thinking of
of what the impacts of that would be
either on your own bank account or on
the environment or things like that so i
mean i think that you know that we've
really kind of been sold this idea for a
long time and it's really kind of
ingrained you know in our and our
psyches you know and i think i mean part
of we've been looking a little bit at
sort of you know the tiny house as a as
a phenomenon in America you know because
America does have this particular
history in this particular relationship
with you know sighs and we have the room
to expand so that's kind of been a part
of the American psychology whereas you
know in other countries who don't have
you know the space to expand it's not
it's not as much a part of the culture
yeah I think it's very cultural um you
know there's I mention American Dream
earlier we've been talking about it and
there's this concept of you know you kid
I think it's I think it's sort of
inherent to a capitalistic society
without getting you know to political
anything but just that if there's always
going to be this sort of competition you
know for for selling things for you
doing things bigger and better and
and I think you put tie that in with the
American dream this concept that anybody
can be successful that you want to show
that you have been successful or at
least in the past and and this is
actually nothing new you know we've we
filmed that at walden ponds you know and
we've sort of looked at the throw story
a bit and check didn't I'd that in
within our filming and he was actually
when he went out and lived by Walden
Pond and wrote well then if he was
reacting to something very similar in
his day where this people tended to have
these really large cut country cottages
and so he sort of in protests of that
and he went and he built a really small
cabin and lived in a full time with his
own hands you know and and so this isn't
a new concept and it's also not the tiny
house isn't a newer reaction to to that
and it's sort of interesting it's you
know America we have a proud tradition
of of capitalism and sort of in living
these like big house we have a trout a
proud tradition of people you know sort
of denying that and choosing to do
something different so yeah I think that
you're going with the sort of throw
history you know and what Thoreau did
was really kind of little things down
into this little space to kind of have
the perspective to really you know view
his life may be from a different lens
and I think the tiny house movement is
really similar I'm over we're not
necessarily saying that everyone should
be sort of like packing themselves into
the smallest space possible you know I
think people need to be comfortable and
people have that right to be comfortable
and they have the right to decide what
that means for themselves but you know
it's really kind of looking at this as
an option for just having a different
perspective on you know what's needed or
what gives people a quality of life you
know and really sort of just taking some
time to reevaluate that and make sure
that you know the path that we're on is
the path that's actually gonna make us
happy yeah I like to say that it's a
it's sort of a reductionist approach to
discovering what's necessary in a home
so it's when you take a house or home
and you strip it down to its barest form
and you and if it still feels like a
home you can look analyze that I've sort
of and say okay well this is what what's
necessary you know so so then as you
build up from there you can choose
things that enhance the quality of life
and you can leave things that don't in
and so it yeah it's really a
distillation of home
you